welcome to this video playing mega jet
set from Australia I don't have also got
the exact name Zhong yuan sow very good
GM I think he's a very high rated up to
50 k we get them get a modern defense
I'm playing him rather classical set up
against that and it seems that he is
going for the hippopotamus yeah on the
hip bone with with age six to come yeah
how to set up pieces here I'd like to
have the night on g3 this always make
some good impression yeah maybe not not
exactly here hmm yeah 94 now it's a bit
miss time to all this yeah I don't
really want to give up this Bishop
huh h3 sh3 mmm the night doesn't have a
square it can take on f2 yeah this is
the problem actually and take on ft
greene takes takes on g5 no that's
nothing and I cannot take with the king
it's completely ridiculous okay so I
need to oh wait wait wait wait I
shouldn't be pre moving that F takes II
might be an idea yeah nitey to was a
really bad move you shouldn't give up
your Bishop here and they had no chance
to avoid it as a term as it doe no
happened
hmm
hmm like to plead you 45
yeah came
some transformation of the bone
structure here he can just take it and
probably is in very good shape 92 p.m.
this is really pain 92 giving up the
bishops are just just very important
here a very important factor this is
just a strategically very inferior
position he's got two bishops and III to
attack so black is an excellent shape
maybe I should have tried with long
castles or something but it's already am
very uncomfortable I've night f1 to
cover that yeah
check
yeah what now I'm not sure that Bishop
f3 as a threat I'm ignoring it for the
moment and detect a six
I don't know if it takes g tags and nice
gotta check on g5 but it's not the end
of the world if I take a six now it's
got 95 95 some bit of a pain but
something else him k money to get out of
95 k so we retreated okay justjust
centralized pieces I'm down on the clock
eyes got 95 now coming to e4 yeah or
that one I have anything that I believe
night c5 was even was even more
problematic
yeah Bishop f3 now I would take f3 and
take your phone should be strategically
excellent from like now yes just an
attacking deform maybe I can go to F to
try to to cover also protecting g5 maybe
Queen have to if I get the Queen saw
from nothing much is going on mm why
cannot take I don't know our FF 125
yeah it doesn't really matter that much
I can now go twin f2 is a helpful
defensive move I don't see a big game it
can play Knight b6 maybe just attack but
I've g5 I can play d 5 might be 65 @ x
the night 96 @ XD for so i need to react
to that okay so this is hanging but it's
not not the end of the world but okay if
i go here he might play Queen before and
some doesn't help me at all
for gone hello Queen to e7 can i
exchange Quincy and this would be
helpful we have the deep one after Queen
trade that should give me some counter
play
hmm
I don't want to give him III
hmm it's not very comfortable
now the slightly weak in position is
always an issue check will create the
some a threat
check
check
check c4s am I need to protect against
f4 night at five
time warning check check check check
draw shefford never offered groom are on
yeah I was bad all the way so I'm
winning on time does feel bad i mean now
maybe no no this is still bad he's got
the h-bomb I just briefly thought okay
I've got this people on but the h-bomb I
was bad all the way this the problem was
right in the opening we're here around
here that's not not much going on it's
just the start of this hippopotamus
formation in a plate 92 which isn't a
bad idea in itself it was just badly
executed I just thought okay he will
play age 697 anyway but of course he's
got Knight f6 and what I need to do is
if I want to do this regrouping I need
to play age for first so that I'm ready
for that if he now plays age 6 that say
here here attacking it I can protect the
ball and everything's okay i have the
Nitra group that can play c3 supporting
the center it's nothing I'm spectacular
for white but it's okay and now in this
position in the game I have no way to
protect that I besides that move and
after night g-form and I need to give up
this Bishop and I don't really want to
do that I can in fact the computer wants
to play this strange move I briefly
consider that but it looks so sick one
ideas that g5 is not working due to that
which I actually saw but I thought a way
what am i doing with the speeds in the
long run I mean if I if he plays that
yeah I can i can play 90 or 92 and and
go to g3 yeah it seems very wacky yeah
after I gave up i need to give up this
this Bishop it's just a very bad
position probably Bishop c4 was also bad
justjust hear me and something like this
is comfortable for black but it's
probably not at the end of the world
okay thanks for watching